I am God you think I'm joking or not you
tell me I'm not joking I'd rather do it
on camera no no no no if it's on camera
we're not doing an interview why we'll
explain why how do you feel about that
influence that you have you better be
careful we're coming for your children
there
buddy yes I'm going to do I'm you're
going to resign I'm going I've been
answering your question you answer mine
it's actually not my job to answer your
questions thank God for talk TV is not
only the home of common sense it's the
only place where you get the truth
[Music]
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk
[Music]
TV tonight on Pi Morgan uncensored
Israel at War the uncensored debate
Muhammad hijab is a Muslim philosopher
scholar and YouTuber whose first
appearance on the show is viewed by more
than 8 million people Rabbi schi boak
has been called the most famous Rabbi in
America is the International bestselling
author of kosher hate and the Israel
Warrior both men are passionate both men
are influential and they both have
vehemently opposing views tonight they
go uncensored and
[Music]
head-to-head from the news building in
London this is Pierce Morgan
uncensored good evening from London
welcome to PE Morgan uncensored debate
about the conflict in Israel is inra
for Israel and its supporters this is
about an existential threat brutally
symbolized by the savagery of the Hamas
attacks on October the 7th for Palestine
and his supporters this is about
oppression spanning many decades Israel
has a unique duty to its people after
centuries of pogs displacements and a
holocaust it must provide a safe place
for Jewish people to live without fear
of being murdered for their faith but
that safe place has taken the place of
the Palestinians and too often has come
at the cost of their dignity rights and
and their lives last week Palestinian
doctor Dr iseline Abu Lees who has lost
25 members of his own family to conflict
in Israel saw a ray of Hope in what
happened in Northern Ireland I met with
Martin mcginness before and he said to
me we were going confronting each other
once we started to move side by side as
equal we put an end to that and that's
what we need the International Community
the world that we can Palestinians and
Israelis to move side by side as equal
with dignity and respect well Northern
Ireland was another conflict which
seemed impossible to resolve it was a
long and agonizing and deadly process
but we got there in the end because both
sides talked endlessly about their
grievances their hopes their needs and
eventually they did Find Unity they find
a way to come together now clearly we're
not going to find peace in the Middle
East tonight but we are going to do
something that doesn't happen very often
we're bringing together two very opinion
ated passionate influential people very
opposing views and we're going to have a
proper debate and we're going to see if
somewhere there is perhaps more that we
can agree on than we first imagined so
thank you for joining me Gentlemen We
tossed a coin before we came on air
tonight and actually you won the the
toss um and you said you want to go
second I defer to my my brother and the
way this will work Muhammad we have four
sections of this debate and at the start
of each one you'll both get one minute
uninterrupted to say what you want to
say about each of the themed uh titles
of each block so you go first and at the
end of your minute you'll hear a sound
and when you hear that uh you end and
then a rabbi sh gets his chance to speak
so the First theme is a simple one are
Hamas to blame you have a minute
Muhammad from now from one perspective
Hamas started the battle because
obviously from October 7th even they
themselves title it to or the flooding
OFA but from another perspective if you
look at from an international law
perspective we're talking about 1967
we're talking about resolution security
resolution 242 in which it is actually
stated that um Israel is in a
belligerent State because they're
occupying the West Bank East Jerusalem
and Gaza and they have been so therefore
the war has been continual for a very
long time according to international law
but let's remove Hamas from the
situation altogether let's remove them
what do you have you have the West Bank
and what do you have in the West Bank
you have
187 children who have been put in
prisons they have been put in prisons
according to bet Salam without charge
you have 44 children before October the
7th that have been killed before October
the 7th in just 2023 alone so if you
remove Hamas from the equation what you
have you have the West Bank you you
remove dominance from the equation you
have the West Bank and what do you have
you have occupation you have settlement
which you condemned rightfully so you
condemned that on your show the
settlement is there okay
R resolution 242 in the UN doesn't
mention a single thing about AG
aggression or aggressor that is a total
fabrication and it speaks about disputed
territories but let's be clear the
occupier of Gaza is Kamas they won an
election in 2006 had a civil war with
mahmur Abbas took the Palestinian
Authority officials threw them off
buildings killed Muslims killed Arabs
Mahmud abas is afraid to go to Gaz he's
terrified of Hamas he hasn't been there
since 2007 and let's be clear Hamas is
an Abomination to Islam sulan salahadin
the greatest Muslim conqueror of all
time after whom the main artery in in
gaza's named he said that you have to
allow all prisoners to be redeemed he
would never hold hostages this is and
remember the Islam is about fair
treatment of prisoners of War Kamas
beheaded Tha non-jewish workers you
asked your last appearance Here For Real
uh firstand sources I'm the firsthand
Source I saw it in kibuts they raped
women they had sex with dead women's
bodies they are evil and do the right
and call them Evil all right we've had a
minute each okay we've got a a
passionate start Muhammad let me ask you
about Hamas I want to first before you
do that I want to commend you P honestly
because bringing me on for the second
time I have to commend you and the fact
that you actually condemned the
settlements is very good but people want
to know do you think the Ida are a
terrorist organization uh no you don't
think they're ter okay well if you look
at the UN definition of terrorist
organization they say killing civilians
for political ask my opinion no but
definition according to un definition is
killing civilians for objectives why are
they not terrorist organiz well well
you've asked me a straight question I
don't think they are Terror organization
so when you see babies like this the
ones who the ones who kill babies like
this are not terrorists it's horrific so
the people who kill babies like are not
terrorists well let me let me respond
let me respond I believe Israel has a
right to defend itself I agree that they
need to get rid of Hamas who are terror
group in this way well here's the
quantry for me morally right why is
quantry though I tell you why with Hamas
is not a country because in war in war
when you declare war as as Britain did
with the Nazis 100 to1 ratio no are
combat a far higher number of children
in Gaza proportionate to population than
almost anywhere in the world so when
they go after very
sadly let me finish
this you have do you are the one who
insisted on equal time I never did but
you will not respect to 30 seconds he's
going to ask you question 30 seconds
I'll come to you he's going to come to
you after let me finish please I am in
charge mad
so my final point on this is
unfortunately in war civilians to ratio
100 to1 ratio 100 to1 ratio yes they get
killed no no not 100 to1 ratio it's an
unacceptable rati get
killed you come you know you know Pi can
I say respectfully and I mean this is no
insult I'm amazed that you're
intimidated by this man I feel I feel
well with all due respect I can speak I
can speak if I can speak me in a second
time I wouldn't bring back if I can
speak if I can speak ra very question no
he does not because I have I have before
he did this debate he went on X on
Twitter and said I'm only doing it if
there's equal time and then he has
violating that I never asked for equal
time I just want to be heard but he
won't even let me be heard let me
explain something to you you said in a
in a video the other day and you can
look me in the eye you said that Jews
are now trembling Muhammad I am no no no
don't interrupt me I am not trembling
it's all on my it's all my Instagram
page now you see this yamaka it means
that I represent something I'm an
ambassador ambassador of Islam you are
talking about a religion that started
the world's first universities educated
women fatim started the first first
University in the in the 9th century in
Fez Morocco now we have a man who says
that he's a representative of he will to
will bring back to top he will defend
Butchery savager he doesn't care thatas
is is an Abomination to Islam because
running away because Islam the children
in Gaza are dying because Hamas uses
them as bulletproof vest the United
States and France and England said
yesterday that the alifa hospital is a
military base it has a tiny veneer it
has a tiny veneer of of emergency rooms
minut but the underneath all of it is a
military base and let me tell you
something if it's true that any of these
countries care about the Muslims in Gaza
because they believe what he's saying
that Israel is killing them this is a
map of all the countries that took place
last week in in Riyad to save the
Palestinians of Gaza from Israel do you
know how many that's Israel a tiny thing
you know how many of them took in even
one Palestinian from Gaza zero nothing
look at that map because they want the
Arabs want to
see the Arabs want to
see don't intimidate me don't bully me
don't intimidate me I've got a better to
ask questions it's a
debate let me let me ask you one
specific question which he raised which
I don't think actually is your belief I
don't think you have defended what Hamas
did on October the 7th I think you share
our unless I'm wrong are they evil
stop
they you're now doing what you accused
him of doing let me ask you what is your
view of Hamas post October 7th I think
that they just like anybody else have to
be examined have to have to look at all
what's your opinion about them yeah I
think that if look here's my opinion let
me be straightforward about this right
anybody who kills civilians anybody
whether it's the IDF I'm consistent in
this manner where if if it's proven with
Beyond reasonable doubt that these
people have killed civilians in both of
our faith traditions in Islam and
Judaism in the Quran is mentioned in the
prophet he said it himself you cannot
kill a woman you cannot kill a child I
condemn them I condemn them that's what
I do straight away whether it's Muslim
whether it's non-muslim whether it's
Christian or anybody else I've already
said that so I'm not being inconsistent
here my question is if that is exactly
the barometer that we're using if that's
the moral reasoning that we using then
we have to say look if you have a 100
to1 ratio and that's what it is 100 to1
ratio and you know how I got this figure
I got this figure from the idef
themselves because they have reported
okay but let me ask you this let me ask
you this does Hamas deserve to stay in
power after what they did I don't think
we should have Hamas in power what I
think we should no let me tell you we
should we should have we should have a
Palestinian Authority with bigger armies
and airports with proper tanks and with
airplanes like every country in the
world you might be right absolutely they
won't allow it isra won't allow how do
you get rid of Hass what you don't do I
can tell you for a fact is try and kill
three thou 30,000 of them with 100 to1
ratio because if you do that then you're
committing genocide because you'd have
to kill three million Palestinians right
by do you know even do you even know the
definition of genocide I haven't said
genocide what's it you just said
it what is the definition of genocide
what's the defition you always claim to
be an academic you're always telling
your rocks areals what is the
definition genocide genci you'll be
genoci genocide is where Target you
target an ethnicity for extinction Geno
ethnicity side murder yes if you do if
you K million Palestinians are you
genoci if you kill 3
million 1.8 million
Muslim who live in total peace in Israel
as equal citizens in fact Israel
practice reverse discrimination against
the Jews because the Jews are
conscripted to fight Hamas so if Israel
excuse me no you will not interrupt me
if Israel you will not interrupt me you
will not interrupt me you will not
interrupt you will not bully me you'll
not drop me I am not afraid of stop
saying now let mear let me be clear sh
over each other well then let then you
need to control your guest with all due
respect control both he said equal time
and there's no equal time now there's no
equal time if Israel was interested in a
genocide of the Palestinians why do they
have 1.8 million equal Arab Muslim
citizens who are in the Israeli Supreme
Court who are onethird of the medical
profession do you know that do you know
do you know that an arabe an Arab judge
put the president of Israel in jail for
accused rape that was mosha katab That's
how little Israel is an apartheid state
genocidal State this man sitting next to
me Muhammad hijab will not distinguish
between self-defense when Hamas comes to
brutalize and murder your people versus
when an army like France
stops retali simply
protect you don't believe the Jews
should have a right to defend say it all
right then then say it the Jew have the
right to defend themselves yes they do
that's why we everybody has a right to
defend right
to they can go to Gaz no they can go but
no hey hold on let me tell you my
position let me tell you so they can go
in than he asked me a question go ahead
answer it yes they can go in to even
fight even Abu AB the the general of
Hamas he said Arab we are waiting for
you that's why he's being hold on you've
asked me a question go ahead they do
have a right what my advoc what I've
been advocating all along is face
to-face confrontation what I'm against
hold on excuse me what I'm against is a
100 to1 ratio because if you
have fine hiding under Hospital what
face to face confrontation
is I'm okay with face to confrontation I
like it block two is ex it's honorable
way block two is exactly this
question
[Music]
we're here good morning everybody hope
you're well thanks for joining us you're
watching the independent republic at
Mike gra right here on talk TV welcome
to Friday night with Nadine here on
prime time we like to speak to the
business people behind big moments good
evening UPS Morgan uncensored in New
York City very impressive well
played I'm 3 days into the job what have
I done wrong and your face just starred
out at me me and you conquer time who
wins you do you know what I love about
tour today we do it all sunak sella
scon are you actually speech writing for
richy soon I'm so rich frankly uh I'm
going to take the side of boozed up
Brits against these pump you mean you're
not going to support mayor Jose L
not stop ping to nimes to the naysayers
and The National Society for the
preservation of the habitat of the
Lesser spotted M the problem lies in the
bureaucracy it's almost like they highly
paid consults don't really know what
they're
doing the first thing they teach you in
weather school is never confuse dog
walkers with Dogers Twitter you sons of
can you please reinstate my account
thank you there's a threat that you'd be
worried about so are you saying that
you're being overwhelmed that you're
inundated we are really working hard for
you and we're just asking patients to be
patient with us
are we only going to be trusting sources
like meta and Google and Facebook and X
formly known as Twitter where is our
where is our unbiased news going to come
from Welcome to the talk it's really
great to be back my Little Darlings kids
think all they have to do is stay at
home be silly take pictures of
everything just shut down Tik Tock then
yeah problem solved there you go who's
fit as a butcher dog him oh
but but he's now middle class ha I
nearly have empathy when I'm speaking to
them I know now you're probably going to
boot me after show
this Kevin O Sullivan is the worst
presenter on talk TV sitting on his fat
ass talking
living got former PMS all over the joint
saying things the last few days we have
indeed yeah great first show you having
fun oh a ton of fun King PE and King
Cube I think there's only room for one
king man you know what I'm saying just
because they're skin folk don't mean
they're kin folk when I say I am God you
think I'm joking or not you tell me I'm
not joking I'd rather do on camera no no
no no if it's on camera we're not doing
an interview why we'll explain why how
do you feel about that influence that
you have you better be careful we're
coming for your children there buddy
about Maring Nation yes I'm going to do
going you're going to resign I'm going
I've been answering your question you
answer mine it's actually not my job to
answer your
questions thank God for talk TV is not
only the home of common sense it's the
only place where you get the
[Music]
truth let's go to the second the second
topic right this time RAB SMI you will
go first with a minute to say what you
want to say and then Muhammad you'll get
yours so the theme is this and the
question is this for Block two has
Israel gone too far in it response to
the October the 7th Terror attacks okay
RAB you have a minute starting now I
just came here by taxi and passed the
statue of Winston Churchill that's in
the lifetime of our parents okay he is
the greatest British Statesman of the
20th century you know what he did when
he had a genocidal threat knowing that
Hitler wanted to eviscerate annihilate
Britain he carpet bombed all of Germany
Dresden Essen um uh Hamburg Israel has
not even gotten close to that Israel
does not send its Air Force to carpet
bomb said he said senin it's military I
have a friend who died six six children
39 cuz he was personally trying to stop
at Kamas Terror tunnel Israel is
surgical Israel is only going after the
fighters Israel has opened humanitarian
corridors for the for the Palestinians
to go south Hamas shoots them and makes
sure they don't go Hamas builds its
military structures right shifa hospital
is this much hospital and it's this much
military they love using Palestinians
and that's why they've stolen their
money they got they got about 16 billion
ion dollar from the inter Community
there isn't one bomb shelter in in Gaza
they don't care about civilians at all
Israel is doing the right thing you have
a minute what I'm saying is the 100 100
to1 ratio comes from the following
figures we know that 10,000 civilians
have died of them according to the IDF
as reported by the guardian 60 dozens
they say about 60 uh Hamas died which
we're being liberal by saying 100 to1
figures for every one Hamas you have to
kill a 100 civilians that's effectively
what we're saying if the tra trory
continues as it is if the trajectory
continues as it is then you have to kill
3 million Palestinian civilians in order
to kill 30,000 Hamas Fighters if you
want to ex extinguish them eviscerate
them annihilate them destroy them you
have to do that now you have Herzog who
is the president that you you
interviewed saying that all Palestinians
they are responsible this man is being
more slippery he's being more slippery
than the lubricants that he sells in his
daughter's sex shop and that's the
reality of
situation did you really just say that
you know you seem obsessed with Jewish
sex it's bizarre yesterday you actually
spoke about Ben Shapiro's wife you
actually you you said to Ben chapiro
your wife's a carrot well you're more of
a man is that what you're trying to say
then you said that Jews that be DSM
you're speaking about sexual lubricants
while people are dying you know Muhammad
get your head out of the Jewish bedroom
it's really bizarre let me ask Muhammad
a question right I don't disagree with
you that so far it seems to me yes
obviously yes a fact that many many more
Palestinian civilians innocent people
are getting killed as retribution by the
Israelis for what happened October 7th
that's indisputable right their argument
is that they're going after a terror
organization Hamas and unfortunately in
war as Rabbi schi correctly said about
what Churchill did in World War II
church was wrong a lot church was wrong
yes he was yes he was was a he all the
British was George the
criminals criminal let me get think
punish you think Winston Churchill was a
war criminal in in standing up to the
Nazis by killing the who killed 12
million people I Believe by doing what
he did was a war criminal by killing in
Dres and Hamburg by indiscriminate
killing Collective punishment my
morality says that's impossible okay
that means the British people who
supported him voted in they just second
the British people believe a war
criminal yes so so therefore you your
belief is that no retaliatory action by
retaliate to the man not to the babies
tell me a war in history yes where
civilians haven't been killed no I'm not
saying civilians haven't been killed
it's Rao
ratio RAB so let me give you a ratio
yeah how many people do the Nazis kill I
don't know you don't we know we know we
know they kill six million they killed
12 million people ining 6 million Jews
right so how many died in how many died
in dresda how many civilians died in
Germany do you know I don't know exactly
right so you don't actually know what
you're talking about I do know what I'm
talking about because I know and Hamburg
you said it's about you if I'm wrong
yeah go ahead if I'm wrong you said it's
to do with the ratios the ratios but you
don't know the ratios when you I know
for a fact call Wiston
Church wait a minute Rabbi SMY when you
call winst Churchill a criminal basing
on ratios you don't know what they are
no I know no we there's difference of
opinion among the the scholars no there
is is tell us the opinions what are they
tell us tell us what they are hold on
there's of how many Dr excuse me stop
speaking for how many am I speaking to
him or you how many in Dres whatever the
number it's indiscriminant I'm against
it no he
doesn't tron's about 25,000 and uh at
the time the the Germans were saying
250,000 we know it's about 25,000 today
let me be let me be clear Winston
Churchill was the greatest Statesman of
the 20th century he saved the world from
I agree Nazi Terror yeah that you could
live in a country that is only around
today because of The Bravery of that man
showing no gratitude is the height of on
topic top stick on topic call all the
British nap the Nazis sck on topic sck
interrupting me defeated the Naz war
criminals his parents all the other
people po
criminals wrong no let me let me be
clear let me interrup let clear
Muhammad hij trades in falsehoods 300
to1 what are you talking about and now
he says now he says the Jews are about
to kill 3
million the fact that this man considers
himself an Oxford academic I was the
rabbi at Oxford University for 11 years
this is a travesty from that this is a
Trav from did you graduate from any I
have a rebal GRU let me answer
communic I am
aun can I speak is pointless Rabbi SMY
is there a limit to the number of
civilians in Gaza that Israel can kill
to try and eliminate H that's a great
question there isk you but let me ask
you not even one not one beautiful
Palestinian child should have to die
because Hamas kicked out M was my
question and yeah and not one should
have to die what what what the answer to
your question is that Hamas if they
surrender unconditionally then okay fine
let them let them allow all the
civilians Israel said that all the
civilians can leave all the civilians
should go south they beg them and that's
something that militaries never do
Churchill did not tell the people in J
come on and and you you came with all
your notes I'm not I'm not here we get
the point moham I this is this is all
this is this is all proof that he can't
debate he has to use these images debate
me we ask you to come on with all your
ex ask good question a member of the uh
cabinet in Israel was actually quoted as
saying that nuclear weapons were an
option that Israel could use a no one's
ever confirmed Israel has nuclear
weapons it's long being suspected that
seemed pretty clear confirmation why why
are you against nuclear weapons if
you're if you're not against res why you
against nuclear let me ask the question
let me ask why you against it I've done
this before this job let me do it go on
okay so when that guy says that if
you're if you're living as an innocent
civilian in in Gaza what the hell are
you thinking that an Israeli government
member threatens the use of a nuclear
weapon which would obliterate pretty
much all of Gaza and everyone in it
thank you for the question if that were
true why hasn't Israel used nuclear
weapons against Naser when he hold on
hold guy and the and the answer and the
answer is no no I know the guy and I
spoke to him about it his name is Amai
eliyahu Israel has never carpet bombed
any ever now7 was preemptive he was
asked a question by a provocative
interview and he said well if you're
going to bomb the same thing like it was
a Muhammed job type you want to kill all
the Arabs three million people just drop
a bomb he said well if you want to drop
a bomb drop a bomb he was being
dismissive and stupid and he put out a
statement the next day saying that never
in history would the Jews ever even
contemplate doing that let's remember
one thing the only place in the Middle
East one
second the only place in in the Middle
East where Arabs have any freedoms
Israel the only place where they vote
openly Israel the only place where
Palestinian women can dress the way they
want Israel the only and let's be clear
when when when Muhammad hijab gets up
and says that we Palestinians want to be
a religion of death you know I just got
a haircut coming here by an Arab Barber
here in London and he said to me I hope
you I hope you defeat this guy because
he doesn't represent us we want to live
we want to have good lives we want to be
religious we want to eat but we don't
want to die from Mar you are not a
Muslim you're an islamist you're ask
Muhammad let me ask mhamad a question
let me ask M question Hamas has
240 Hamas has 240 hostages they took
including babies sure young kids sure
grandmothers who survived the Holocaust
I mean an unspeakable further criminal
act we can agree right of course why
should Israel agree to any
ceasefire so long as those hostages are
still being kept hostage look um my
position is very clear they should fight
man to man on the on the ground that no
that fighting that's exactly what
they're doing that fighting no one can
this is that's exactly what they're
doing man to man they took hostages they
took babies he's asked me the
question let him answer the question
you're getting excited here I know it's
your sexuals you're the sex RAB you're
back
exited he's getting excited with me let
me ask the question you guys answer them
Muhammad answer my question why if
you're Israel would you ever agree to a
ceasefire if those hostages aren't
released I'm I'm telling you what my
position is my position is man-to-man
combat which is what they're doing now
no that part of it is understandable do
you understand that's what they're doing
no problem but what I think is not
understandable what is not acceptable
because you said what's the
proportionate response that's the
question you keep asking everybody my
answer to you is a proportionate
response is one where in which the
ratios are not 100 to one your invention
excuse me I would say that Hamas by what
they did on October the 7th ver1 wait a
minute wait a minute wait a minute
ordered by by doing what they did they
ordered de facto the disintegration of
Northern Gaza that we're seeing of and
all the civilian seen the death of
thousands civilians they knew what was
going to happen I agree that's why they
should go in 20 in 2005 Israel
unilaterally withdrew from Gaza and
allowed well Hamas won an election 2006
they could have built Singapore you know
what they did they took larger foreign
aid per capita than all of Europe
received from the Marshall Plan and look
what France and Britain look how
beautiful London is they took that money
and they bought bullets and bombs they
did not build hospitals not schools they
stole it from the Palestinian people
isma hania is worth 4
billion I don't
care call him call him evil
criminal say he won't he say he will
never condemn because he has no I have
heard him do it EXC no no he condemned
hamas's attack he's never condemned
Hamas let me ask you do you condemn
Hamas on what basis here we go see you
accept now let let me ask let me ask you
a question every answer is on what basis
what this this what's your SCE even if
you ask me if you do condemn IDF I'd say
specify your context in what exact cont
do I do you defend Hamas as a terrorist
organization that just went and killed
12200 people burned them alive beheaded
them and took 250 hostages you
them or not do you condemn them or not
get your head get your head into the
debate and do you condemn them or not
see this is a this is a debating Fact
Two now him it's two on one it's become
two on1 him you're not a victim stop the
victim but now it's two on one stop the
victim you love portraying yourself as a
strong man now you're a victim it's two
onone you probably could take two on-one
so answer it answer the question is
Hamas a terror organization you condemn
it's a reasonable question because you
asked me the IDF a ter okay beautiful
I'll answer your question
directly Hamas is as much a terrorist
organization yet no Hamas shouldn't be
called a terror organization if if if
the IDF isn't why because either both
either both or neither okay but just to
extrapolate your position because you
believe the IDF is then you're also
saying that Hamas is let me tell you my
position say it say
it let RAB let me get the answer the
unho won't let me speak right I'm asking
my the first rme the whole could be
friends given you've already stated you
believe the IDF is a terror organization
yeah yeah am I am I to assume legally
Legally or well hang on go I'm going to
assume that you believe Hamas is now no
this is what this is my position but you
have to give me 10 seconds at least to
answer right legally I think you
shouldn't call Hamas a terrorist
organization if you're not calling IDF a
terrorist organization that's my
position because call him Terror hold
hold hold on hold on hold on hold on let
me finish because if the as we said the
UN definition of what a terrorist
organization is to kill civilians in
order in order to achieve a political
objective however on a moral and
theological philosophical level I agree
with rosalin Higgins who was the Justice
of the international criminal court
right the court of justice icj British J
by the way she was a holocaust Survivor
as well she was Jewish and her position
is that she believes that the word
Terror ISM or terrorist is actually
useless and she says that it's I'm
putting to her can you question going to
let me finish so I'm answer your
question so I'm saying that as a moral
construct I think it's a neoc colonial
social construct used by people in order
to to label some people as terrorist
other people as so as a moral category I
don't designate it as a
moral legal do you believe do you
personally Muhammad believe that the IDF
and Hamas are both Terror organizations
I think yes if if you if you say if you
say yes to IDF you should say yes to
Hamas you say no to ask is a terrorist
organization you believe if you say yes
to IDF you can say yes to Hamas no I'm
ask you what you believe yes I believe
legally according to the definition if
you say yes to Hamas you can say yes to
IDE Pi Pi Pier we can go on for the next
I've got we all say no to the IDE next
years F we're going we're going to the
next we're go to the next
block
[Music]
we're here good morning everybody hope
you're well thanks for joining us you're
watching the independent republic of
Mike gra right here on talk TV welcome
to Friday night with Nadine here on
prime time we like to speak to the
business people behind big moments good
evening I'm Pi Morgan uncensored in New
York City very impressive well played
I'm three days into the job what have I
done wrong and your face just stared out
at me me and you conquer time who wins
you do you know what I love about tour
today we do it all sunak sella
scon are you actually speech rating for
the I'm so rich frankly uh I'm going to
take the side of boo du Brits against
these pomp you mean you're not going to
support mayor Jose
l
stop panding to the nimes to the
naysayers and The National Society for
the preservation of the habitat of the
Lesser spotted M the problem lies in the
bureaucracy it's almost like they highly
paid Consultants don't really know what
they're
doing the first thing they teach you in
weather school is never confuse dog
walkers with Doggers Twitter you sons of
can you please reinstate my account
thank you there's a threat that you'd be
worried about so are you saying that
you're being overwhelmed that you're
inundated we are really working hard for
you and we're just asking patience to be
patient with us are we only going to be
trusting sources like meta and Google
and Facebook and ex for you know as
Twitter where is our where is our
unbiased news going to come from Welcome
to the talk it's really great to be back
my Little Darlings kids think all they
have to do is stay at home be silly take
pictures of everything just shut down
Tik Tok then yeah problem problem solved
there you go fit as a Butch's dog him
all right but but he's now middle class
here Tess I nearly have empathy when I'm
speaking to him I know know you're
probably going to wo me
up this is talk
[Music]
TV is peace possible okay uh not on this
basis right but we've got to try and get
to Peace So we get a minute each again
uh Muhammad you'll go first uh this time
so you get a minute from now Justice is
a prerequisite for peace in South Africa
when the apartheid system which we know
for a fact Israel is an apartheid state
because it has laws like the right of
return which only only only allow Jewish
people to come into the country and if
they convert by the way to Christianity
or to je to Islam they are stripped from
that right which is it meets completely
the definition of a party that's po
Coral law school and according to the UN
convention 1973 it's an aparte system
and as a prerequisite of an aparte
system you have to be a racist if you
support that you're a racist no about it
so number one 1973 apart law if the
black South Africans have been displaced
if they have been displaced by the
whites and then they were try to come
back into their country and they were
not allowed and then you ask them as
peace possible that's not the question
we'd be asking them we' be asking them
as just as possible and that's the
question that we're going to be asking
because he can all sit there and talk
about all these things where the IDF his
son Mendy is being attacked by vibrated
by the the rockets and he's selling him
and his door selling by to the
public unnecessary thing at the end
again I hope you keep that in one minute
on is peace ever possible of course I
Revere countries like the United Arab
Emirates Dubai Abu Dhabi where I've
spoken several times I am safer as a Jew
wearing a yamaka in Dubai in Abu Dhabi
than I am on the campus of Columbia
University or even Harvard these days
the Muhammad bin bin zad is just an
incredible leader um I saw in the Gulf
States the Islam that Muhammad hijab
rejects but the Islamic World Embraces
that's why they made peace with Israel
it's a technologically advanced tolerant
forward-looking very traditional very
religious Islam and that's and that's
why and that's why they've made peace
with Israel and peace will continue to
be made all of these countries are
praying for Israel to destroy Hamas
because Muhammad isab is an outlier he's
an extremist and his views whether his
views as he represents them at Speaker's
Corner of things about women being
subject let me just let me just be clear
all of the Arab countries want Kamas
destroyed and that's and the proof is
when they had their conference Riyad
last week they did not even once call to
bring in any evacuees because they want
Israel to establish a more democratic
regime in Gaza which will they will do
Israel follow to both of you right just
give me a very very quick snapshot of in
20 years time how peace could have been
achieved very quickly okay the first
thing is when Israel withdrew in 2005
almost 20 years ago um if Hamas had not
come to power if they had taken all the
international Aid that they got um tens
of billions of dollars peace would have
been achieved by building businesses
entrepreneur okay we get there now by
destroying Hamas making sure that
there's Democratic elections let the
Palestinian people not mhammed not you
both agree Hamas should be gone right we
can agree on this right we agreed that
there should be a bigger Palestinian
Authority with
armies we do have
agreement and the way we have in the
history of the world no two Democratic
Rockets uh Powers have ever gone to War
that's why since the end of the second
world war there's been no war here in
Europe we need to see a democratic Gaza
Hamas won an election 2006 now by the
way in correct because it's against the
Tyranny no I said no two democracies
ever gone to war Putin is not a
democracy he's a tyrant in the history
of the world no two democracies have
ever fought a war if we have a democracy
in Gaza what does peace look like in 20
years peace looks like the Arabs voting
for their rulers voting and backing them
uh seeing Israel as a partner not being
humiliated that because of this tiny
little red dot Sur humiliation two State
solution I well you
know I'll tell you I'll tell you I'll
tell I'll tell you if if if two State
solution is aamas State wanting to
eviscerate Israel he doesn't believe in
it but he doesn't believe in a two
solution he believes in a Final Solution
that's really scares me you don't
believe in a solution final solu you
speak about Jew in
final do you believe in a two if that
second state is
Mexico if that second state is Gaza then
of course not because it'll just become
another genocidal enemy wanting to wipe
Israel off the map that's pretty
unequivocal he doesn't really want a
two-state solution I don't want a
two-state solution that's a that's
that's a terrorist state to destroy I
personally believe this whole question
should be left to the Palestinians of
what kind of solution they want however
having said that this man has written in
his book a war in Israel that is the
settlement write a book called a war
it's called the the Israel Warrior
something thank you thanks for plug
fantastic I apprciate fantastic in that
book he writes that the issue of excuse
me the issue of settlements that me and
you both condemn peers I do yeah yeah
yeah we do he doesn't condemn it because
he sees a an ancient biblical reason to
be in that whole land I think is I think
Arabs in Israel should be able to live
wherever they want I want Arabs to live
in Jerusalem I want Arabs to live in T I
want Jews to live there I don't believe
in the is I don't believe in Arab I am
so proud that Israel has 1.8 million
Arab Muslim citizens who are protected
by the idea he calls the idea of
terrorist what you should be less proud
of is the rapid expansion of these
settlements on the West Bank has been
incredibly deive it's been in my view
illegal it's been declared
illegal
many there are many things I'll defend
Israel about that is inde let me answer
let me answer if you go to places in
Judean Sam in the West Bank why call Jud
like because those are the Biblical land
who cares why do you cost something
Arabia it's the
Arab you don't know history it was
always your day and Samar the West Bank
is the West Bank of a river we don't
callia the West Bank of the Mississippi
River now let me go back let me go back
let me go back if you go to the Baran
industrial park in J Dan Sam you will
see I've met the Palestinians I've
interviewed them they are paid 20 times
the salary working for people you call
settlers they want them there it brings
civilization it's only jihadis who don't
it's only jihadis and that's why you're
that's true yes it is true I've
interviewed many many Palestinians who
definitely do not want
want under M with no
democracy afraid to criticize ja M my
friend MH go ahead conversation you're
wearing my favorite blue color of course
I'll let you speak fantastic for that
reason brilliant you just because uh I'm
wearing the blue my mother loved that
color and
she I thought it would have been because
of Israel because you oh that's right
you wore the Israeli C
today can you shake hands no please I
don't want to cuz your hands shaking
your hands are sh sorry I mean look how
it's peaceful you would shake my hands
no I'll shake hands with you you
wouldn't shake my hand after what you
said today about me I can't shake your
hand but here's ask me what you said
about my sex life and I'm shaking your
head stop stop I just want to say you
won't shake my head you won't shake my
head I guess it will be no you know you
know what he said there is a little bit
telling because you know the blue colors
and Israel and that kind of stuff he
defended DS which was Jeffrey Epstein's
uh lawyer for that very reason because
he's a supporter of Israel I defended D
when I fought over him going toar you
don't know
anything
abismal and Alan d had a
huge defending qar is come on guys get
back to did you go to the island
Muhammad Mohamed years
mad this
this I wrote a book koser sex for
marriages I didn't write get other
people's bedroom I don't care about
either of your sex lives okay he seems
interested in mine years time I'm 20
years time what does a potential piece
look like I don't know but that's that's
a speculative question to be honest you
ask me hypothetical you I don't know
you're asking me hypothetical question I
asked you a hypothetical you said I
don't do hypotheticals I want you give
me hope why did you don't answer my
hypothetical question if you're asking
me question that Belfast question why
huh remember I asked you the Belfast
question and you didn't answer it I
don't think there is the only parallel
why you answer that one because they're
different situations no but it's
hypothetical you're asking me
hypothetical now why you have to answer
I'm just asking you no but why do you
have a d don't think asking you how
peace look like it's hypothetical no
it's talking about the future hypothe
how would you let me rephrase it how
would you like it to be resolved this
okay fantastic okay okay look yeah let's
look at history Riv to the Sea that's
how you want it right no Israel let him
answer don't answer for him honestly
you'll be surprised to to know this and
people talk about you you said this I
have to correct you I looked at the
Hamas chart Hamas themselves yeah in in
article 16 even they say you can have in
article 31 they say that you can have
peace between they can have a shared
line between Christians Muslims and Jews
they even say that I I think the most
radical elements everybody you want the
jihadis these one that one no one
actually wants the extermination of
Jewish people that's that's a lie
actually that's not true the wa wa Let
Let
Me Charter you know let me speak H
Charter calls for the Hamas Charter says
that behind every single tree and stone
where a Jew now you're saying that
the it says that every Jew has to be
murdered
deny that you know you have what Sayes
theth says in the end of it's an esic
it's an esic which says that on the end
of times there will be a war and there
will be trees and stones that say behind
me is a is a Jew uh killing so Muhammad
is saying that the Jew this is a Hadith
which has been miss so does it mean what
does it mean it means that it's anical
it's not an imperative does it mean it's
not an imperative are you o ACC not okay
I'll tell I'll tell you pick and Sho
pick and shoes ask you a question let me
ask you a question is this a theological
question so I'm answering you this
Hadith is called an esic you know this
because you're a theologian it's an
eschatological Hadith it's not talking
about it's not imp it's not like 1
Samuel chapter 15 verse number three
where it says Go and Kill the men women
children donkeys and oxen which by the
way netan who quoted he
quoted it's not like that see this this
is this is the blood Lial of saying the
Jews want get a word
here let me put a point to I'm going to
put a point to tell you who wants the
absolute annihilation of every Jew they
can get their hands on all the Hamas
terrorists who crossed the border on
October 7th who gleefully recorded it
boasted about it and the Hamas offic
wait a minute and the Hamas official
spokesman who only last week said they
want to do it again and again and again
if you don't
think are wedded as an organization to
the annihilation of Jewish people you
are
living their Charter it says that they
will
murder that I agree with hold on let me
tell you I agree with this agree both
the IDF and Hamas on paper say they
don't want the annihilation of Muslims
and
jeow meow says that's not true I'm Hamas
Charter says explicitly that every Jew
will be murdered by Hamas they are a
genocidal
you're you are lying sorry nobody can
hear either of you the point is in my
estimation after October the 7th Mass
are now a openly boastful
genocidal terrorists calling their
parents saying I killed 10 the luced
party in 1999 had a charter and in it
they said they want the whole of Israel
including as he believes um the West
Bank and Gaza and everything if we are
going to because there they say they
would kill Arabs equal ciens will be
equal citizens let me finish let me
finish they're not equal cuz apar laws
no there's no apar law the apart so let
me explain that let me let me get now
you can go to Portugal and Spain and
show that if you have ancestry they give
you citizenship that's Israel you Jewish
no every country listen this is the
country Arabs or not Muhammad muhamed
let me speak let me speak we live in a
we live in a Christian country Who The
Sovereign head of state is a Christian
I'm a Jew I never felt alienated from
the fact that this is a Christian
country Arabs live as equal citizens in
Jewish St
you know wait a minute I'm the
astonishing can ask each other questions
Muhammad had two Jewish wies but you
won't shake the hand of a Jew and you
know why that's not Islam that's
islamism islamism is is sub it's we're
going to the
final we're here good morning everybody
hope you're well thanks for joining us
you're watching the independent republic
of Mike gra right here on talk TV
welcome to Friday night with Nadine here
on prime time we like to speak to the
business people behind big moments good
evening I'm Piers Morgan uncensored in
New York City very impressive well
played I'm 3 days into the job what have
I done wrong and your face just stared
out me and you conquer time who wins you
do you know what I love about tour today
we do it all sunak sella
scon are you actually speech rating for
RI sunak I'm so rich frankly uh I'm
going to take the side of boozed up
Brits against these pomp you mean you're
not going to support mayor Jose I
not stop panding to the nimes to the
naysayers and The National Society for
the preservation of the habitat of the
Lesser spotted M the problem lies in the
bureaucracy it's almost like there
highly paid consults don't really know
what they're doing
the first thing they teach you in
weather school is never confuse dog
walkers with Doggers Twitter you sons of
can you please reinstate my account
thank you there's a threat that you'd be
worried about so are you saying that
you're being overwhelmed that you're
inundated we are really working hard for
you we're just asking patients to be
patient with us are we only going to be
trusting sources like meta and Google
and Facebook and X form you known as
Twitter where is our where is our
unbiased news going to come for Welcome
to the talk it's really great to be back
my Little Darlings kids think all they
have to do is stay at home be silly take
pictures of everything just shut down
Tik Tock then yeah problem problem
solved there you go who's fit as a
butcher do him all right but but he's
now middle class here Tess I nearly have
empathy when I'm speaking to them I know
know you're probably going to me off
show
this Kevin O Sullivan is the worst
presenter on talk TV sitting on his fat
ass talking for a
living got former PMS all over the joint
saying things the last few days we have
indeed yeah great first show you having
fun oh a ton of fun King peer and King
Cube I think it's only room for one king
man you know what I'm saying just cuz
they're skin folk don't mean they're kin
folk when I say I am God you think I'm
joking or not you tell me I'm not joking
I'd rather do it on camera no no no no
if it's on camera we're not doing
interview why we'll explain why how do
you feel about that influence that you
had you better be careful we're coming
for your children there buddy they all
Mar Nation yes I'm going to do you're
going to resign I'm going I've been
answering your question you answer mine
it's actually not my job to answer your
questions thank God for talk TV is not
only the home of common sense it's the
only place where you get the
[Music]
truth
I'm going to end the show by you both
having a minute uninterrupted sure to
summarize right let go first no problem
how you think we move on from here
because clearly anyone watching this is
going to see two completely intractable
sides right this is what I see on
Twitter all day long right I see people
on the Israeli side and on the prop
Palestinian side and they scream at each
other all day long right they say some
things that are right some whatever
get you involved in it well you both
said to me before we sat down I don't
want Tove himself speak another term but
you both said to me independently two of
us ging up in him finally well you both
said to me before we started you said
that the American uh Jewish Community
were very pleased of what I done on the
show and you said that the Muslim world
please what done on the show and I took
that as a perfect extrapolation of what
we've been trying to achieve which is
giving both sides a voice and a platform
I let me my minute what do not
what has not worked is bringing you
together like this because actually it's
been a an ear thumping screaming match
so you're now going to get a minute each
to summarize right and in the summary I
want to see if we can at least pretend
to be constructive here right because
the world needs this somehow to end okay
so RAB you go first first of all
Muhammad thank you very much for wearing
the Israeli colors thank you for your
support of the Jewish State we greatly
appreciate it I should have done the
same secondly uh I I'm sorry you
wouldn't shake my hand I will shake your
hand anytime because I do believe what
Pierce said we have to have peace and
Harmony going forward it's a shame that
you said no
third peace will come my Arab brothers
and sisters who are the green on this
map accept that tiny little thing that
I'm covering with my finger that tiny
little thing called Israel and when they
understand that Israel is not the Jewish
homeland Israel is actually the great
Arab hope if our Arab brothers and
sisters get the economic prosperity of
Israel the rights for women the rights
for freedom of freedom of assembly to
criticize their governments without fear
the way the people inamas in Gaza would
be murdered by Hamas let alone in
Palestinian Authority they'd be thrown
in jails Israel is the great hope let me
just say this Islam is a great world
religion it created the world's first
universities it introduced agricultural
reforms in Europe under Sultan Akbar in
India 400 years before Europe you had um
you had Al Razzi who introduced medical
reforms 600 years before the the and if
we return to that kind of Advance not
the Islam that is being advocated by
Muhammad which is Antiquated
Andes then we will have peace so God
bless my Muslim brothers and sisters and
I will shake your hand anytime Muhammad
a minute for you as I said before and
I'll say it again Justice is a
prerequisite for peace if this was the
case that it was South Africa and both
Nations had a long and known history
with each other Israel and South Africa
there's a book called The Secret
Alliance that you can read for your
further information if this was South
Africa and the blacks were kicked out of
their country they were kicked out of
their country by the White
like the
700,000 Palestinians were kicked out and
then they had the audacity to talk about
peace nobody would be accepting it the
apartheid laws of South Africa are the
same effectively as the apartheid laws
of Israel you're not allowed to come
back to the country unless you are of a
specific ethnicity which meets the
requirement for aparti they 100 to1
ratio of being killed in Gaza this seems
to be acceptable to shoy Unholy schole
it's seem to be acceptable to him
it's not acceptable to me it's not
acceptable to the people when we see
these images it's absolutely not
acceptable so peace is justce
requirement for Peace by the
way you don't get to go all doesn't
matter what your name is I found that
quite a dispiriting hour I've got to be
honest with you doesn't matter I thought
both of you let yourselves down I gave
you a great opportunity here we gave you
come on well fine you can say what you
like about we gave you an audience you
gave
it's fine it's not just about the
audience it's about a big audience which
we're getting for all these shows about
a big audience seeing people try to come
nobody here has seen you try even try to
come together whyp spirting to me what
can I do PI with all your respects and
try hard you know I believe I believe I
believe in N Mandel Nelson Mandela could
have gone down this road when he came
out of prison after 27 years and they
called him a terrorist they called him a
terror wait a minute he could he could
have come out of prison and he could
have taken the path of Vengeance he in
he was violent instead you talking about
he took the path of Peace he took the
path recation when he came out of prison
he took the path of Peace he was violent
terrorist terrorist I take constructive
criticism and I will think about what
you said Mandela was but I will tell you
he was
against but I will tell you I will tell
you if you bring two people on to a
debate and you're saying that we let you
audience don't give L
successful very successful and you will
allow I'll be quiet one one one to bring
up don't give them lesson stuff that is
so just embarrassing like sex people's
sex
lives did not no I did not I oh I'm
proud of my books on sex but this is a
debate about I don't care about your sex
lives either of you seem to be really
interested for me whatever'll talk later
keep it on sensor good
night
[Music]
[Applause]